hey this is presh talwalkar
the manchester evening news reports the
impossible question on gcse exam that
had 16 year olds across the country
stumped
i'm going to present a version of the
question and show one way to solve the
problem
circles a b and c are in a row such that
a b c is a straight line segment
circles a and c
pass through the center of circle b
and circle b passes through the centers
of circles a and c
circle b intersects circle a at the
points d and e
and circle b intersects the circle c
at the points f and g
consider two different regions
one region is bounded by the arcs bd df
and fb
and the other region is bounded by the
arcs b e e g and gb
if each circle has a radius equal to 4
work out the total area of the two
shaded regions
give your answer in terms of pi
i thank joe for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
before we work out the answer i want to
suggest a strategy that you can use to
solve all types of problems like this
first connect each circle center to the
other circle centers intersection points
points of tangency and other special
points in the problem
a second strategy is to break down areas
into circular sectors and polygons
if you apply these strategies you'll be
able to solve nearly every single type
of problem like this
so let's apply the strategy to our
problem
we'll connect the centers a and b and
then connect the centers b and c
each circle has a radius equal to four
so a b is equal to four and bc is equal
to four
now let's construct a d and a e
then we'll construct b d and b e
then we'll construct b f and bg and
finally we'll construct c f and c g
we now can break down the areas into the
following shapes
adb is an equilateral triangle
because each side is a radius of either
a or b
or both
and each side has a length equal to 4.
so adb is an equilateral triangle
we also have equilateral triangles bfc
aeb and bgc
in between the equilateral triangles and
the remaining arcs in circle b
we have the following circular segments
there are eight in total we'll now solve
the problem in the following way
let's focus just on circle b
the area of circle b is equal to two
times the area of the single blue region
plus
four times the area of an equilateral
triangle plus eight times the area of a
circular segment
if we can calculate everything except
the two blue areas
then we'll be able to solve for the blue
areas in terms of the other areas
so let's calculate the area of a
circular segment
this is equal to the area of a circular
sector
minus the area of the equilateral
triangle now the area of a circular
sector is equal to pi r squared
multiplied by theta degrees over 360
degrees
here r is equal to 4 and theta is equal
to 60 degrees because the circular
sector
is one of the angles of the equilateral
triangle
so we substitute in and then simplify to
get the area of the circular sector is
equal to 16 pi over six
then
the equilateral triangle's area is equal
to s squared multiplied by the square
root of 3 all over 4.
each side length is equal to 4 so we
substitute in and then simplify to get
the area of the equilateral triangle is
4 times the square root of 3.
let's just put that over here by the
area of the equilateral triangle as well
we'll now simplify this to get the area
of the circular segment
it's equal to 16 pi over 6 minus 4 times
the square root of 3.
so we'll substitute in
we finally calculate the area of circle
b
this is equal to pi r squared which is
equal to 16 pi
now we want to calculate
two of these blue regions
and let's just label that as x
so we now have an equation 16 pi
is equal to x
plus
4 multiplied by 4 times the square root
of 3 plus 8 multiplied by the area of a
circular segment where each segment is
equal to 16 pi over 6 minus 4 times the
square root of 3.
all that remains is to simplify this
equation and solve for x
so we'll just simplify this equation
and we'll group terms that have a square
root of 3 and we'll group terms that
have a pi together
so we get 0 is equal to x
minus 16 times the square root of 3 plus
32 pi over 6
we then solve for x to get that x is
equal to 16 times the square root of 3
minus 16 pi over 3 and that's
approximately equal to
10.958
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
you